let me also explain to you and your
audience
how the founding fathers as a whole
understood the issue of slavery because
it's simply not true
that all founding fathers uh were slave
holders
that's just not true
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report reminder guys to subscribe to our
youtube channel and click that pesky
notification bell
and joining me today is a professor of
political philosophy at clemson
university and author of the new book
america's revolutionary mind a moral
history of the american revolution and
the declaration that defined it
see bradley thompson welcome back to the
reuben report
hi dave great to see you again it's
good to have you brad uh well we have to
do what we legally have to do first
which is i have to ask you how you're
coping with covid how's it going down at
the university how's life what's going
on with the school
and the rest of that stuff before we get
into the book sure
everything's fine here the university's
been closed now for about two months
we finished the last month of the
semester or so
online which was new and different but
it actually worked pretty well i teach a
seminar with
10 students and we did it by zoom and
that was fine
but otherwise i've been sitting every
day all day
in my what i call my redneck office
which is
outside here in warm south carolina
and working on writing my next book
you're a capitalist i know that you
teach about capitalism
you're a free market guy how do you feel
about the state of capitalism and the
free markets in the midst of this
lockdown
well i don't feel very good about it i'm
i'm
actually genuinely worried about where
this country is headed
and i don't mean just the current
economic crisis i mean it is ironic to
me
that um that uh china
passed along this uh coronavirus to the
united states
and in response our government is
turning more into
the chinese government we're becoming
considerably more authoritarian
than we ever have been before and i'm
genuinely concerned
about the freedoms and rights of
ordinary everyday people to go up
to go about their business to work and
to live their lives
so i've had a bunch of different
senators and economists on
talking about you know what to do with
stimulus and all this stuff from marco
rubio and rand paul and a couple other
people
um what would be the sort of pure
capitalist approach we've got you know
something
creeping up to now 40 million unemployed
people we're not
letting enough people go back to work
you know some of the states are doing
things
a little bit differently but as you know
i'm here in california we're you know
we're still in lockdown now they're
telling us until
august even though we flattened the
curve we did what they asked uh
yet they seem to still roll out these
draconian measures what what's the right
policy if you believe in free markets if
you believe in capitalism and you
believe in human ingenuity
yeah i i think the simplest and the
first and foremost thing is you
uh government i think probably has an
appropriate role to protect
uh those who are most vulnerable to
protect the elderly
and i think veterans facilities and old
folks homes
could have been on lockdown but i don't
think that the rest of the country
should have been on lockdown
and we are free um rational
um individuals and we have rights and
each of us has to assess the risks
ourself and we have to take the
appropriate actions
uh that we think will protect uh
ourselves
our families our co-workers uh and the
members of our community and i think
americans
have by and large done exactly that i
mean it's been remarkable
uh what what ordinary everyday free
people can do
um to protect themselves i mean nobody
wants the coronavirus
and i think the americans without the
government have done an extraordinary
job
uh in uh taking the necessary steps to
prevent getting it
so what do you think the role of the
government then is at the state level
and the federal level what do you think
the role
is when they're not letting people go to
work is the
is it to to bail out everybody is it to
help small business big business some
combination thereof is is there a role
at all
yeah i i don't think that there's really
very much role
certainly for uh uh for
pay for paying the american people not
to work uh and for all of the bailouts i
mean
because i i would have had a um a
lockdown that
would have been much much less draconian
um and so therefore the economy would
have
would have uh not been burdened by this
and ordinary everyday americans
uh uh would have just continued working
all right so let's let's shift to your
book because some of the things that you
talk about in the book
actually probably everything you talk
about the book we can frame around sort
of what's going on with us right now
and as i was reading it i thought man
this guy hits every
word that has any any meaning to me but
i'm just going to read
the first couple sentences of the inner
flap because i think that really can
almost set us off for the whole rest of
the conversation
because you're really trying to do two
things in this book that i think you do
quite well
so it says the purpose of this book is
twofold to elucidate the logic
principles and significance of the
declaration of independence
as the embodiment of the american mind
and to shed light on what john adams
once called the real
american revolution that is the moral
revolution that occurred in the minds of
the people
in the 15 years before 1776.
so that's the part that i'm super
interested in right now
because it seems to me in 2020 with
corona and everything else that we
are in some sort of idea
churning state right now that maybe
could 15 years from now we'll go back
and go whoa
this is where a lot of these ideas
actually started so let's
let's start with the first part though
uh the declaration of independence as
the embodiment
of the american mind can you talk about
that a little bit
yeah sure so in 1825 just before he died
thomas jefferson wrote a famous letter
in which he described the object of the
declaration of independence
as um as an expression of the american
mind and that statement has always
struck me so that
that that indicates that the declaration
of independence is a kind of summing up
it's it tells us what americans were
thinking
in 1776 it tells us what they what they
thought
their moral and political principles
were and
and the declaration lays out four
self-evident truths and i think those
four self-evident truths
are at the heart and soul of what the
american revolution was all about
uh and and subsequently what the united
states of america
has always been so it is the declaration
is the heart and soul of of the united
states it is it provides
the moral foundation so it's on the one
hand
it's a summing up of the principles of
the revolution but it's
more than that it's also um a statement
of who and what we are as a people it's
at the heart and soul
of the philosophy that i call
americanism
so you mentioned those self-evident
truths and we hold these truths to be
self-evident that's what it says in the
declaration of independence
uh why is in and of itself is that so
important
this we hold these truths to be
self-evident that we don't have to
re-litigate that some things
are because they are yeah so i think the
first and most important thing to note
dave
is that the revolutionary generation
actually believed in the i in the
concept of truth
they believed that there are certain
moral principles
that are objectively absolutely
permanently and universally true
and that is very different from the
world in which we live
today so can you lay outside yeah can
you lay out some of those principles
just so we can put them in contrast to
kind of where we're at right now
yeah so i mean the first thing to say is
we live in a post-modern age
uh and in 2016 the oxford uh dictionary
uh described its word of the year as
post-truth and time magazine ran a cover
uh asking the question is truth dead so
in 21st century america
we no longer believe in the in the very
concept
truth and that is dramatically different
from what
the revolutionary generation believed
they as i said they believed
in the concept truth that there are
absolute certain
morally universal principles and
the particular principles that they
believed in
the four self-evident truths of the
declaration which are contained
in the second paragraph i think each one
of them can be summed up
in one word and they would be first
equality second rights
third consent and fourth
revolution now you have to read the
second paragraph to
to get the full flavor of of those four
self-evident truths
but that is the core of what john
thomas jefferson referred to as in my
view
the american mind so let's preempt
the haters who will say wait a minute
how could equality
be in there because not everyone was
created equal we know men and women were
not equal we know these were slave
owners
et cetera et cetera we've talked about
this a little bit before when you were
on the show last time
but can you uh can you unpack that for
us a little bit
yeah so that's it it's both a
complicated
and obviously now a controversial
subject particularly in the light of the
new york times's 1619
project so i'm sure your audience and
you of course
you're very familiar with the 1619
project the purpose of which
is to argue that america was founded not
in 1776 but rather
in 1619 when the first slaves were
brought
to the united states and what that means
of course is that
the united states is is founded
on slavery which therefore means that it
is by definition
immoral and evil right that is
in some what the 1619 project is all
about
but america's revolutionary founders in
1776
rejected the idea of slavery but let me
unpack that because that's obviously
complicated so the first thing to note
is that in 1776
slavery was the norm around the world
there had always been slavery
through all time over all continents
slavery was had universally been
accepted around the world
the second thing to note is that in
1776 no founding father supported
slavery as an institution they regarded
it as
a what they called a necessary evil
and the emphasis has to be put on the
word evil now take
thomas jefferson for instance he clearly
and explicitly states
that slavery is an evil
immoral institution why because it
violates the doctrine
of rights he also believed that slavery
was an
inherently corrupting institution
all right so those that's what's
important to say
at the outset now let me also explain to
you and your audience
how the founding fathers as a whole
understood the issue of slavery because
it's simply not true
that all founding fathers uh were slave
holders
that's just not true and so you can
divide
the revolutionary generation i would say
in into four camps
so first there were founding fathers
like john adams
for instance samuel adams who never
owned a slave and were morally opposed
to slavery
and then there's a second camp um
people like benjamin franklin and john
jay
who created the first anti-slavery
organizations in the united states but
earlier in their lives they had been
slave holders but certainly they came to
condemn
slavery and then you get people in the
third category like
george washington who yes was a
slaveholder his whole life
but upon his death uh freed his slaves
in his will and then finally there's the
hard category consisting of people like
patrick henry
and thomas jefferson who own slaves
and who did not abolish uh or
did not free their slaves upon their
deaths
so how are we to evaluate that
i think the first thing to say is that
both
say patrick henry and thomas jefferson
as i've already indicated with jefferson
were adamantly opposed to the
institution of slavery
they if you read their private
correspondence they
lamented uh slavery they saw themselves
as
morally culpable but
they didn't abolish their slaves and the
institution of slavery i think for two
primary reasons the first
actually i'd say three reasons the first
is that they thought slavery would
eventually die a natural death
about that they were mistaken they could
not have imagined in 1776 the invention
of the cotton gin
secondly both
both henry and and thomas jefferson
were deeply concerned about what i call
the post-emancipation problem
and by the post-emancipation problem
what i mean is
it's the question of all right so we
free the slaves today
which is the morally right thing to do
but then what
and jefferson himself was deeply
concerned about the possibility the
very real possibility of a race war in
the southern
uh particularly in the slave majority
states
so the question is how how do you free
your slaves
without creating um any kind of
of of race war between whites
uh whites and blacks so i mean these
these were the big issues and then the
last thing i would say dave
is it is important and i try to do this
in my book and that is to hold someone
like thomas jefferson
morally culpable he was a slave owner he
didn't free his slaves and part of the
reason he didn't free his slaves
is because of his own personal um
his own personal habits his lifestyle
jefferson
lived lived high and
and when he died he died in debt and as
a result
of of living the lifestyle that he did
um he didn't have the resources
he thought to to free his slave so we
have to judge
uh someone like thomas jefferson uh as
morally culpable
there's of that there can be no question
yeah
so it's interesting we talked about this
last time but you know when you visit
monticello which i've been to
probably five or six times which was his
estate in virginia
you know they spend when you go on the
tour they spend what i would say is
almost a disproportionate amount of time
talking about slavery which in a weird
way
it's positive even though it feels
disproportionate it's it's sort of like
we're not shying away from this i mean
they they are very open about it and it
does go to the
the complexity that they're they're not
saying he's not culpable
or anything like that are you ever
concerned that when when you write a
book like this and when you and when you
talk about
these great minds that founded the
country that so much of the conversation
gets funneled to the slavery issue not
to diminish
the the importance of discussing it
obviously but that so much of it seems
to go in that direction because of the
way we look
through a racial lens in 2020 or at
least the media does or
or many of us do i am concerned about it
because it's not what defined
the american revolution and it's not
what defined the american founding
in fact i would argue just the opposite
so rather than
actually lamenting the fact that it
always comes up i take it as an
opportunity
to tell people that the declaration of
independence
authored by thomas jefferson is the
single greatest document in human
history
that led to the abolition of
of slavery and in in the in the decades
immediately after uh the publication of
the of the declaration
the northern states in fact every single
northern state between 1776 and 1803
uh passed manumission laws where they uh
put in place laws that would lead to the
gradual
emancipation of slavery and then at
the federal level um the the federal
government
in 1787 passed the northwest
ordinance which prevented the extension
of slavery into the northwest
territory which is that was the land uh
west of
of the appalachian mountains um through
ohio and indiana and then secondly there
was
uh the prohibition in the constitution
of
of the atlantic slave trade ending in
1808
so given the time given the reality
on the ground they did
i think as much as was possible given
the circumstances right so it's it's a
hard question
it's complicated but uh in my view
um in the end the founding fathers um
are are vindicated by
the principles that they enunciated
which led
and and the united states is in many
ways
i mean it's its history of anti-slavery
is is simply the greats one of the great
stories of american history through
through the 19th through the 19th
century um
and so yes we need to tell the story of
slavery
but we also need to tell the equally
important story
of how and why slavery
was ended in the united states
so i want to back up to those
self-evident truths because it's one of
the topics that i'm actually most
interested in right now and i write a
little bit about
in my book that that there has to be
something outside of
us to organize a society
do you know how much sort of internal
arguing they had as to what those
self-evident truths were
actually and how they all arrived at
what they were
yeah that's a great question so i would
say
that the principal division uh amongst
colonial americans
in the 1760s and in the 1770s was
between uh american patriots
and the so-called loyalists or american
tories
that's the great division and and in the
end they had
really very different conceptions of
what america ought to be
and they had very different conceptions
of the underlying
moral principles of the united states
but once the declaration of independence
was passed that
disagreement became moot
and i think what's most important and
the story that i try to tell
in my book is the story of how
and why american patriots came to
search for discover
and develop the principles that would
ultimately be
elucidated in the declaration of
independence and so
you know going back to your first
question um and the twofold purpose of
my book
so on the one hand yes the book is about
the declaration of independence
it's a close textual analysis of the
declaration
particularly of the four self-evident
truths
but the book actually in the end dave is
about a lot more than just the
declaration of independence
it's about the american mind and it's
about the deepest
causes and meaning of the american
revolution
so as i said the declaration is a
summing up of those principles but the
real question
the really fascinating part of the story
is how the americans
came to those principles because they
didn't hold them necessarily in say 1760
right these were principles and let's
take
um let's take any one of of the four
self-evident truths
equality rights consent and revolution
um these were principles that the
revolutionaries
discovered and developed so for me
the key year is 1765.
and 1765 is the year in which the stamp
act was passed
and that's the moment when everything in
america changes now the second
quotation uh that really drives my
interpretation of the revolution as a
whole in addition to the one by thomas
jefferson
describing the declaration of
independence is one
um by john adams uh and john adams late
in life
in trying to describe to a friend
what the causes of the revolution were
he he says that the causes that the
revolution was not
the war for independence the true
american revolution he says
was put into effect in the 15 years
before
a shot was ever fired at concord and
lexington
and the revolutions the true american
revolution
he says was a moral revolution
in the minds of the people so
that's what my book is really about the
moral revolution
that occurred in the minds of the
american people and adams's
statement is supported by thomas paine
who at that time also in describing the
causes
and meaning of the american revolution
said that because of the
american revolution the american people
he said
hear with new ears see with new eyes
and think new thoughts and the new
thoughts he said
had to do with the doctrine of
individual rights
it's the discovery of the doctrine of
natural rights
by the americans that really is the most
important i think revolutionary moment
and so what
what my book then does is it takes each
one of the four self-evident truths
equality rights consent and revolution
and it gives a kind of intellectual
history over
i devote two chapters to each of the
four
self-evident truths and i trace a kind
of intellectual history
of let's say the idea of equality or
rights
from the late 17th century from the
english philosopher john locke
up through the early 18th century but
then really i spend most of the time in
the book discussing
how the americans developed these ideas
during the 1760s and during the 1770s
and that's really how the book is is
framed
and that's that's really the story that
it's telling how the americans
discovered these principles so i want so
we did
equality i want to do i want to hit on
the other three more
um but first as they were
debating these things you know one of
the things that i talk about all the
time is they were saying there are
truths outside of us
and then they're saying these are
god-given rights and then also we're
separating church and state
that concept is is pretty profound uh
at least in our modern times that that
men could do
something like that um were they all
sort of on board that was there was
there any pushback that
we we can't well i guess well it's
church and state certainly there was
pushback but that we can't say that
there are truths outside of us
it will lead to anarchy or something
like that
well i think it's true to say that every
single american revolution
believed in the idea as i said earlier
of truth
of absolute objective certain permanent
universal truths
but the question is what is the source
of those truths
right that's the really that's the key
question
i can also tell you that virtually every
single american founding father
believed that for instance the concept
of rights
was grounded in nature and by nature
i mean nature out there right you look
out into the world
uh and you see nature and one of the
really important things
that the founding fathers did was they
adapted
the the ideas of
17th century english scientists and
philosophers like francis bacon in his
novum
organum and sir isaac newton in his
principia mathematica and john locke and
his essay concerning human understanding
and they they they took the
enlightenment's ideas
of the laws of nature the scientific
laws of nature and they attempted that
to apply them
to man right and they asked the question
are there
moral laws of nature
which means laws that are absolute
permanent and universal right that you
can look out into the world and you can
identify and so
and in order to discover those moral
laws
and rights of nature then you have to
study
human nature and so all of america's
founding fathers
were students of the enlightenment they
believed that there were moral laws
and rights of nature that could be
discovered by examining
human nature um
the the more difficult question and
where you do see some division
is yeah i think it's true to say that
most of the founding fathers were
practicing christians
and so therefore they believed that the
laws
and rights of nature were grounded in an
ultimate source then that ultimate
source of course was the supreme being
as he's called in the declaration of
independence now but it's also the case
that not all of the revolutionary
founders uh were practicing christians
um and so they they discovered the laws
and rights of nature
in nature and they just they didn't go
the next step but the most important
thing to remember
is that they all believed in the moral
laws and rights of nature and nature is
the key term there
so with all of this in mind you're you
know talking about the enlightenment and
how they were incorporating these ideas
and you know
had traveled you know literally across
the world to to form this new nation
in a weird way was this sort of timing
is everything that made america so great
that it was sort of following the
enlightenment finding a new land like
there was the opportunity and in many
ways
uh had the timing been a little bit
different uh
and they wouldn't have been able to find
this new land right then
that these ideas really never would have
taken root the way they have
no i think that's right right so these
ideas
never really quite took root at least
socially
and politically in the old world where
those ideas came from
right so there is there is something
about
the american experience the american
experience of
leaving europe and and discarding all of
the old world
manners and mores and uh
and institutions ideas
and starting de novo starting
in a new place and they were able
to put into effect ideas
that they never really could have put
into practice in the old
world now eventually you know beginning
with the french revolution and then over
the course of the following century
many of the i these ideas were
eventually put into practice
in in the old world but you you should
view
america as a laboratory
right a laboratory where
free men and women come
and they are able to experiment socially
and politically
and they are able to put into practice
ideas that they simply
would they would not have been able to
put into practice in europe and so
i think it's a combination of
these ideas coming to the new world and
then the fact that that
they have a blank slate right they they
get to begin
with a tabula rasa that is america
which was not possible in europe and so
it is a kind of fortuitous meeting and
that's one of the one of the ways i
think about it when i think about
what america is there was kind of a
fortuitous meeting
meeting of the ideas of the declaration
of independence
which passed through the cumberland gap
uh after the revolution uh and where
american uh pioneers like
davey crockett and daniel boone implant
were able to implement those
ideas in a place
that that had no
institutions so it was it was an
extraordinarily fortuitous
meeting of both ideas
and a place that had no heritable
institutions
it's funny because it almost sounds like
a miracle in a lot of ways
that all of these things came together
as these people are traversing the new
world
and they're having this awakening and
that's why at the beginning of this
conversation i sort of likened it to
what i think
is happening right now i i sense
although it feels very authoritarian
right now and draconian and kind of
scary especially
you know if you're if you're in
california where i am it's like there
are
people waking up i think people are
suddenly realizing what individual
rights are what personal responsibility
is
we may not see the fruits of that in the
next election
but you know if if this all goes
according to plan i suppose you would
say well we'll see the fruits of that
in about 15 years yeah i think that's
probably right i certainly hope it's
right
um i still believe and and i do write
about this a lot in the book so one of
the key concepts
in the book is this idea of the spirit
of liberty
and that's one of the key moral concepts
uh i think of the american revolution
was that what i call the american
spirit of liberty and i don't think any
people in
any place at any time anywhere in the
world
has had what i call this spirit of
liberty i mean there's no other way
to explain the american reaction to the
stamp act
in 1765 without understanding what this
spirit of liberty was
i mean if you think about what the stamp
act or the sugar act or the towns and
acts were
i mean they were i mean certainly
compared to today these were relatively
small taxes
on the american people but it wasn't
just the taxes
and this is this is actually directly
comparable to the united states of today
so you can think about what the british
government was doing in this
to the colonists in the 1760s and 1770s
as something akin to the british deep
state
the british st deep state um not only
taxing and regulating the colonists but
imposing
draconian uh regulations enforced
by uh by the military uh on
on on the american people and so it's
not just
you know it's not just the rallying cry
no taxation without representation
no the american people really saw
a much larger sort of web
of of um
laws and regulations that were being
imposed by this kind of british deep
state
and it ignited in them i mean the
americans
in during this period they they were um
they were sort of overwhelmed by this
kind of
and edmund burke the british statesman
speaks of the american spirit of liberty
he had never seen anything like it and
so
the stamp act was like a tripwire that
the americans stepped over
and it ignited the spirit of liberty and
the spirit of liberty is first
and foremost um a recognition
of of power and what power can do
to ruin the lives of people so the
american revolutionaries understood
i mean their basic operating premise is
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely they understood that
principle
to the core of their being and the
second they saw even the
slightest intrusion of political power
on their lives either in the form of
taxes
or regulations or british troops
the trip wire was hit and they reacted
immediately
and i do not believe that the american
spirit of liberty
in 2020 is dead i think we are seeing
the american spirit of liberty
uh being enacted by all kinds of
americans
all across the country particularly
those americans
who have been forced by the government
to not
work right so in many ways you could say
that our situation
in may of 2020 is considerably
worse in terms of our rights and
liberties than it was in 1765
and i do think ordinary everyday
americans are
are ready to stand up for their freedom
yeah well i love that i love that you're
seeing it too and it's not just rattling
around in my brain but
you know i keep telling people i'm
seeing in in los angeles when i walk
around now
and i'm walking my dog and neighbors
come up to me and they know who i am and
they'll say you know dave i'm starting
to think about things a little
differently
and you know this is the bastion of l.a
progressivism
over here so i do think there are some
good things happening so let's go back
to those four things so we talked about
equality we talked about rights let's
talk about consent
yeah so consent um was also one of the
early rallying cries of the revolution
um so the the most famous rallying cry
in 1765 no taxation without
representation
representation is the idea uh
that um that that our government
officials
have received the consent of ordinary
everyday people
to make laws for them but the purpose of
these laws
is to protect the rights of of
individuals
so the third self-evident truth
of the declaration that what i call the
so-called consent truth
says that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
right so the pr it says that the purpose
of government
the sole purpose of government is to
protect the rights
of individuals it does not say that the
purpose of government
unlike certain um certain
uh conservatives today it does not say
that the purpose of government
is to promote let's say virtue uh
it says it's to protect rights that is
to say to create
spheres of freedom for individuals but
the key though is that at the heart of
the principle of consent
is the idea of self-ownership it says
that each and every
man and woman owns himself we are
self-sovereign we are self-owning
and therefore self-governing
and because we are self-governing
a legitimate government only receives
its
legitimacy if it is based on the consent
of each and every individual now it
doesn't mean unanimous consent
but in in the context of the united
states it's majority consent
um but we all consent to live by the
rule of the majority
which of course has its problems because
majorities can often
be tyrannical uh and this is precisely
the point that james madison makes in
the 10th federalist essay
so there's always a delicate balance
between between
consent uh and the protection of rights
but
consent really is um
one of the one of the core principles of
the revolution
and it's one of the core principles of
american
civic life so you mentioned something
that's like bouncing around a lot on
on twitter over the last couple of
months that that a certain set of
conservatives think
that it really is to protect virtue or
or a certain sense of morality uh
something like that um what would you
say to those guys when they say well if
we don't protect
virtue now of course now that becomes an
amorphous term depending on how they see
virtue
but if we don't de uh defend virtue or
morality which they usually tie very
close to
religion uh that then individual rights
ultimately will be trampled upon anyway
that you sort of need
that as a precursor yeah when when did
government ever make men moral right um
you need freedom to be moral the the
best
inculcator in my view of virtue and
believe me there is no greater proponent
of the importance and necessity of moral
virtue
in society than than than myself i mean
in my view you you to have a free
society
you have to have a nation of moral men
and women you cannot have a nation
made up of moral reprobates that goes
without saying
so um i i i stan no man
you think we sometimes need them do you
think we sometimes need some morally
corrupt people
so the i mean we've made it somehow 40
minutes without mentioning the t
word but in many ways trump to me is
something like that like this is
obviously no
great moral virtuous person but in many
ways he was the
hammer that we needed to sort of shake
up the system
to break a lot of bad things that had
been sort of calcified
but but didn't do it out of no one's
looking i don't even think the biggest
maga supporter is looking at trump
thinking oh this is the greatest moral
man
on earth but in a weird way he was the
necessary tool
do you think that is that possible to
bridge that divide
well sure i mean i i do think it is just
a
it's a fact two facts that you've
mentioned first donald trump
is not a paragon of personal moral
virtue
but on the other hand um no no
politician in my lifetime in fact i
would say
of the last 70 years uh
has done a more important job of going
after the deep state
the deep state is something i think that
is real uh
and and and the date the deep state also
includes the mainstream media um and so
uh trump has launched uh a three and a
half year
uh assault on on all of the certitudes
and platitudes of of the the deep state
and and i do think that's been an
extraordinarily
uh important um development in american
political life
so do you sort of separate that from
morality in a traditional sense or is
that a type of morality actually
well i mean it's it's a type of morality
if it's directed at
um breaking down um
tyrannical power right so
sure uh the defenders of freedom
uh and i'm not suggesting that trump is
necessarily a defender of freedom
because he's certainly passed
i think a lot of laws that
have been antithetical to to freedom but
in the sort of in the macro
picture he's done many things
reducing taxes massively cutting
regulations
but most importantly you know is its
identity
i would say the single most important
thing that he has done is to i is
literally just simply to have identified
the deep state right and then to be
attacking it on a daily basis which
as i've said includes the media that
that has
that itself has been one might say a
kind of revolutionary act
yeah well it feels like we're kind of in
one right now
um so revolution since you're talking
about revolutionary acts that that's the
fourth one
that they found to be self-evident
that's probably the scariest one for
most people and
especially in a weird time like this uh
let's let's talk about that a little bit
sure so
i think the most important thing to
remember dave is that
america is a revolutionary nation
and what i mean by that is we were
founded by a revolution
um we were we created a new nation
de novo out of nothing on a
tabula rasa but
built into the principles of the
declaration is
the idea that whenever any form of
government
becomes destructive of those ends or
purposes which is the protection of
rights
the declaration says that the people
have the right to alter
or abolish that government right
and that truth and it was meant
to be a truth not a truth specific to
1776
but a universal permanent truth so
it applied in 1840 it applied in 1940
and it will apply again in 2040.
america is a revolutionary nation
however it's also important to note that
uh in the declaration of independence
the first
word that appears after the fourth
self-evident truth the revolution truth
is the word prudent
and what that means the importance of
that is that
you know you you you can't have some
crazy guy
living out in the in the in the woods of
idaho
declaring war on the american government
right
uh revolutions are dangerous things and
america's revolutionary founders they
understood that it's a dangerous thing
and you can't
you can't try to overturn your
government
for as the declaration says light and
transient
causes right so jefferson never would
have said
that that with the passage of the stamp
act
that would be appropriate to overthrow
the british government
but according to jefferson when you get
the sugar act in 1764
the stamp act in 1765 the declaratory
act
in 66 and then the towns and acts in
1767 the tea act
in 73 and then most importantly the
coercive
and prohibited prohibitory acts in 1774
and 75
jefferson says look there is there is
clearly self-evidently a design
and that's a word that you see in the
declaration and you see it in the
revolutionary literature
there is a design on the part of british
imperial officials
to enslave us to deny us our freedoms
and rights
so if if each of those laws had been
passed by the british government
separated by 50 years each
there probably would have been no cause
for revolution but when compacted
in a in an 11 or just really it was a
10-year period
jefferson john adams uh george
washington
even said oh oh look this
these are not just passing acts these
are not mistakes on the part of the
british
parliament that or or george the third
we can clearly discern a pattern
and that pattern leads in one direction
and that direction is slavery
so yeah i mean it's it's pretty chilling
because listening to that it sounds
alive today i mean again i'm here in
california we we flattened the curve and
now they tell us august 1st and on july
30th i sense that they'll tell us
november 8th
and you know it's like so what do you do
in in a modern sense what would what do
you think the founders would have
us do as we watch governments that
aren't transparent that don't really
tell us why they're doing things that
are
keeping us locked in our homes and not
letting us go to work i mean what does
that type of revolution look like in in
a modern
sense because as you said if these
things if these laws had
taken 50 years in between well then you
don't kind of realize it it's not as
self-evident
but as we find every few months there's
there's a new odd law
law or it's not they're not even laws i
mean their edicts basically being placed
yeah so i think it begins as we're
seeing now
across the country of it begins with
small acts of disobedience
right we see a barber in detroit
um who uh refuses to be shut down
and is cutting hair and is prepared to
go to jail we see
the operator of a gym in new jersey
reopening against the governor's orders
and and willing being willing to to go
to jail
uh as a result of of reopening and we
see americans starting
you know gofundme campaigns to support
these people
um so it begins with small acts of
disobedience now there are of course
formal things that we can do we can
petition our government we can assemble
we can peaceably assemble and we can
protest
but in the end dave the single most
important thing is
we have to vote with our feet uh we have
to vote with our feet here and now and
then we have to vote with our feet
on election day and you have to we
always have to remember
that our government officials are really
nothing more than a representation of
who
and what we are as a people and so
therefore
if you think your government is corrupt
what you're really saying is that on
on some level in some way we the people
are corrupt right but um there are
moments in our political lives when
the spirit of liberty the the
revolutionary spirit of liberty
is reawakened in us and i think you're
right i think this
is one of those moments in our national
history when when that
spirit of liberty which has been
sleeping for many decades
i think it has been reawakened and
and the american people i don't think
um i don't think a majority of american
people
i don't think we've crossed that
threshold
where a majority of american people
are willing to roll over and just take
it
our work is cut out for us it's a great
book and i love the fact that we were
able to link it to so many other things
happening
today so stay safe and i hope
are they telling you you're going to
open up are you going to be in classes
in feb in
the fall uh apparently we will be we we
will be back uh in the fall but it won't
be
face to face necessarily some teaching
will be online
some classes you teach uh face to face
one day and then
you're online the next day so there's a
whole spectrum of
ways that they're going to reopen but of
course as you can well imagine
at clemson university the single biggest
question is
will there be football i saw it coming
all right brad it was great seeing you
thanks a lot we're going to link to the
book right down below
wonderful dave great to see you thank
you so much if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our academia playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell